en plongeant les mentos dans l'eau
gazeuse synchro qu'une réaction en
chaîne des bulles d'oxygène
ouais ça va péter népal alors c'est un
mélange d'eau et de maïzena baïse et là
on va rappeler ce que c'était pas de
farine
donc je viens c'est de l'amidon de maïs
alive voilà donc la schl à ces jeux là
là c'est fluide voyez en revanche si je
suis en mouvement ses impressions que
c'est une cata cela tu fais en mourir et
la cdu auriez là c'est dur qu'ils
arrêtent up est alors grandeur nature
imaginées
j'ai rempli se bat là ouais l'appareil
c'est fluide et a laissé comme de l'eau
près ces jours ci je mettais dans moi je
ne m'en fais pas ah ouais mais bon vous
avez pas vous enfoncez beaucoup de
regarder oui oui c'est vrai ou faux pas
une expérience de merde alors moi je
vous fabriquer du gaz carbonique et je
vais parler sous contrôle du professeur
castaldi cartonné très très bien cette
expérience il n'a pas arrêté de m'en
parler
il n'a même pas je n'en ai pas pu ouvrir
le trucage
non il va aller je l'ouvrais mal on m'a
dit souvent au dernier moment alors
excusez moi je vois là je fais ce que je
peux dire ça c'est la glace la brea
carbonique alors il faut pas la
manipuler clément surtout pas je vais la
mettre là dedans
ouais mais là il faut de l'eau en
revanche les anneaux elle est là merci
merci
et attention regardez bien ce qui va se
passer dans les classes il va se passer
c'est que ça va créer du gaz carbonique
qui sera plus léger que l'air c'est bien
ça un plus lourd plus lourd pardon
regarder voilà ces ripoux annoncé match
combien en avez déjà la meilleure
concert bah oui c'est vraiment de la
merde je vais vous montrer que quand on
remplit un sac de congélation en
plastique qu on le remplit d'eau on peut
le transpercer avec des crayons sans
culot s'échappe du web un bail ou à ta
merde
l'armée a fermé le matin la page 8 le
faire voilà oui mais des affaires
michèle impossible je serai pas toujours
là au bac tu seras toute seule ma [ __ ]
bon bah tu seras tout seul tu seras dans
la merde dans une merde noire même si
vous pouvez me le tenir après c'est
lille qui paie tout a mal fini on va y
arriver le foot la voilà voyez si je
fais ça et ça va alors une balle de ping
pong
ouais c'est très inflammable à temps et
ses gardes quand même pas né sous le feu
de la pensée mauvaise que lui faisant
perdre au jeu l'enveloppent légèrement
repris là où elle avait après la grille
ouverte où là je ne sens pas du tout là
c'est un peu dangereux mais normalement
se mettait à faire si tu le laisses une
cheminée ne le fait pas chez vous non
non pas du tout je laisse une cheminée
je laisse une cheminée pour la balle de
bris qui va créer quoi je crée le feu
poussez-vous isabelle ça s'appelle le
fumigène maison avait fait gaffe à ton
cents à son attention écartée je ne suis
pas le fumigène
normalement la salle là ça commence à
brûler bon moi je me bats il va tout
péter ce qu il d'ailleurs un problème
c'est que ça brûle pas laisser pourrir
les moines et les deux là ça fiasco j'ai
une bouteille en verre j'ai de l'eau à
l'intérieur ceux de l'eau normale
je prends une balle de ping pong heures
et doute vrai jeu rebouche la bouteille
oui ayalon elles sont pas bâlois ne
tombe pas vrai at on est regardé chez
vous chez vous qui fait la france avec
relève l'auteur
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai un magnifique cercle oui
formé par des bonbons à m'entraîner
conneries pour aider à la caméra à
l'épaule et assiettes creuses
ouais et je vais verser à l'intérieur
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer expliqué
nous qui va y avoir une sorte de dessins
de mosaïque de couleurs multicolores sur
cette assiette
c'est ça la ccin les coûts ça va être un
renard non c'est le résultat est très
jolie j'étais très jolie principe on se
régale magnifique en fait ça font quoi
mais la merde en boite nom est passé
c'est une oeuvre en work in progress
live de secret c'est très bon et c'est
en est restée à fond à temps les bonnes
et ward et pearl away sa sénat cette
fête des périodes il faut avoir un soda
d'une marque on ne citera pas plus d des
mentos voilà l'aimons tous prions à
trévise est en fait il ya plein de
petites aspérités laxiste qu'on appelle
des espaces son physique des espaces de
nucléation est élu il explique bien que
jamais en plongeant les manteaux dans
l'eau gazeuse synchro qu'une réaction en
chaîne des bulles d'oxygène qui
correspondent à remonter à la surface et
provoquait an passé qu est ce qui me va
j'espère que ces critères explose en
voici le jeu doit améliorer leur a
laissé le frère c'est un professionnel
ouais ça va péter n'est pas c'est beau
avec cette bouteille d'eau et se poivre
je vais vous montrer l'attention des
molécules à la surface de l'eau ne sais
même pas ce qu'elle dira si elle est là
alors à la surface de l'eau les
molécules d'eau formée de membranes
dites tendues
donnez-moi l'antisèche sur la table et
du poivre
mais le coup de poivre vous allez voir
que le poivre serait parti de façon
uniforme sur l'ensemble du truc je vais
mettre du liquide la station ce coton
tige oui oui lorient maintenant ça vous
allez voir que le liquide vaisselle va
faire que le poivre se dispersent sur
les bords de l'assiette c'est génial
j'ai connu on va terminer on va terminer
sur cette expérience va bien voir vient
voir deux présidents de frais ouais
connais le huawei ait marre franchement
pas mal
[Musique]